hey everybody welcome to led live have
you ever wondered
is there a connection between climate
change and religion
find out on this episode of led live
light exposing darkness so welcome back
today's discussion is going to be a good
one
and i get a chance to have a very
special guest today
brock meyer is my brother and so
he's been on the show before so this
isn't his first time but welcome back
brock
yeah thank you and we're excited because
um the topic that you're bringing to the
table here
is one that i think a lot of people have
questions on
and you know they they see that the
world is gearing up or should i say
falling apart
at some point and we we know that this
has to
be foretold in the bible right that
we're going to get to this place
but how do we know how to apply it how
to not i think that's what
i'm really excited to find out today
yeah absolutely i mean this is such a
huge
topic because climate affects every
aspect of our lives i mean not just in
the weather
but i mean the social climate the
political climate um
and even the actual physical climate and
so yeah i think
a lot of us are wondering what in the
world is happening as we're watching the
world
fall apart around us and it's something
special to to us as well as
as a ministry for the gideon rescue
company because we see
this is our this is our whole field is
responding to disasters and we're seeing
them
explode across the board like never
before
um so people are asking those questions
so tell them a little bit for those that
don't
know who gideon rescue is what is gideon
rescue and what what what is
this ministry that you're working for
yeah absolutely it's uh it's a disaster
response
um volunteer team and we go in and and
try to help where we can but we have a
we have a bigger mission because
it's one thing to just physically
respond to disasters but
we really have a burden to share with
people
hope for what's coming you know even in
the darkest moment in the crisis that
they may be facing we want to give them
solid hope solid information
biblical information that they can hang
on to and say you know what
i may have lost everything i may have
lost loved ones i may have lost property
but god has a plan and i can see how
he's working out that plan to rescue
me not just not just for today but for
eternity
so you've responded to some like what
what kind of things have you guys done
the disasters we've been to a lot of big
storms you know hurricanes tornadoes
that's uh that's always a big one
hurricane dorian in the bahamas
and uh these storms are just i mean
they're they're they're exploding across
the
the board even the experts can't keep up
so i mean you know like
they they project their model and they
say oh this is gonna be a category one
hurricane
and overnight it becomes a category five
hurricane well which is biblical right i
mean you're seeing
natural disasters more frequently and
more intense and you're seeing it
firsthand right
exactly well done talk a little bit
about the bahamas because
that was kind of i mean every one of
these disasters they always say this is
unprecedented i've never seen anything
like this in my life but talk a little
bit about what made that one unique
well you know from eyewitness accounts
that that's what was really um
actually surprising even to us because
we knew it was a large storm it was a
category five storm that sat
over the bahamas it was really
uncharacteristic it didn't move off the
bahamas it just sat and churned
right out of the bahamas and we were
speaking to
a dear saint she was there being
evacuated
and she she actually told us some
interesting things
number one she said this was not a storm
that anybody had ever
seen because they're used to hurricanes
in the bahamas i mean they've seen
hurricanes before
some of the older generation they've
been through some large category four
and category five storms
she said this is a very different storm
because in the middle of the storm not
only was a category 5
hurricane but they they reported that
there were multiple
tornadoes like coming out of the sky and
touching down huge tornadoes in the
middle of a hurricane so you have
a hurricane with tornado activity um i
mean
unprecedented yeah we've never ever seen
that we've never seen that before and
she
she went on further she said do you know
do you know why these things are
happening
and i thought it was really interesting
i said well no like what's your
perspective on this why do you think
these things are happening and she said
well
she said it's because the bahamas we
claim to be a christian nation
and she and she said and yet the most
evil
practices happen right here in our
islands i mean if you follow anything
about jeffrey epstein and all the other
things that have happened
i mean all that stuff happens like in
the most beautiful serene places there's
some really dark
evil that takes place there um and so
she she pointed that out you know she
said that
uh that was a result you know god was
was withdrawing his mercy because
you know they're not living up to their
uh
you know christian profession wow that's
an interesting perspective and i'm sure
we're going to develop that a little bit
more as we get into this because
uh yeah people are going to start saying
the reason why some of these things are
happening is because we have forgotten
god and i think that's the point is that
in the midst of incredible tragedy all
of a sudden
the conversation shifts just from what's
happening politically
physically um you know to something
spiritual
right and and people make that
connection very quickly they're saying
wait a minute
like you know that's why insurance
companies call these things acts of god
you know natural disasters acts of god
now obviously is god the author of evil
and destruction no
but does he allow things to happen to
try to get our attention and wake us up
absolutely
right right right nice so what's
interesting is that in revelation 8
11 actually chapter 11 we have this this
verse that is just really powerful
because
in the context of there's these 24
elders they're all gathered on the
throne
they're worshiping god um and they have
this this
um you know basically song of praise
that they're uttering but at the end of
that song
they tag this interesting line uh in
verse 18 where they say that
that those that destroy the earth
them or god would destroy those that
would destroy the earth basically
and so it's interesting like does god
care about our climate
and i think the answer from the bible is
absolutely right when you go back to the
beginning like
he created adam and eve as basically
caretakers
of this earth i mean they were to be
stewards of this earth
um and through you know obviously
disobedience and
transgression and the fall of man we
lost that
that position to take care of earth and
from that time we've really been
struggling i mean even if you look at
the antediluvian world
like you know they really struggled with
being good caretakers or good stewards
of the earth
and look at what happened i mean the
flood right right
you know it's interesting because we
have a lot of technology in our world i
mean we
can fly around i mean you know they're
they're they're getting pretty advanced
with what they're able to create
and yet we still have these older
technologies that we know are ruining
the earth
and they won't get the new ones because
they're too worried about the money that
they would lose in the
oil companies or whatever rather than
introducing some kind of
mode of travel that would be you know
kicking out oxygen instead of carbon
dioxide you know it's like
we have the technology to do these
things but often it's our selfishness
that keeps us from it so yeah i can
understand that from a biblical
perspective
we are destroying the earth if we have
the power to change it and we don't
it's it's it's uh it's us that's doing
this yeah and
according to the scriptures god
obviously takes that very seriously that
there actually is a
time of reckoning that's coming for
those that specifically destroy the
earth
right um and so you know climate change
is something that's very dear and near
to god's heart
and i think it's because he's put us in
this position to to be stewards and take
care of
of our planet so we don't argue with
that at all the question though
becomes interesting because obviously in
light of this discussion things
quickly turn to the religious you know
like
if if the problem at the heart of the
matter
is the selfish human heart then how do
you regulate that
like how do you put a stop to that right
and so we're seeing this as governments
and entities and churches and religions
are trying to
to you know grapple they're trying to
wrestle with well how do we regulate the
human heart
well you really can't legislate that you
know you can't
you just can't but there's gonna there's
there's obviously an attempt right you
can
already start to see it where they're
like well should we apply carbon tax
should we start forcing people into
doing this or that or
um but you know really it comes down to
a condition of the human heart which the
only remedy of course is found
in god's word have you ever heard of a
sin tax
i actually call it a syntax where they
text more on products like
tobacco and alcohol and things like that
so yeah i can kind of see
what you're talking about right
absolutely
yeah yeah yeah yeah so you know it's
interesting and we've seen this
um you know and jesus predicted this you
know if you go back to matthew 24
jesus lays out like basically a road map
because
his disciples are asking the same
question like what what what are going
to be the signs
before you come like we want to know
like what are the
road marks you know that we're gonna see
um before you come
and so he lays it out you know matthew
24 he says well the first thing he says
is that many are going to come in my
name
right and that's a real interesting fact
because we've seen that like the
from from the time that jesus left to
now
there has been there have been many many
many people who have come claiming to be
some sort of messianic figure yeah i
remember watching all these videos
there's this dude in australia
who claimed he was jesus man next guy
had tons of followers
and it was like really like people
actually really believe this guy's jesus
totally
and they do whatever he wants them to do
they give them all their money and
these dudes are flying around in private
planes it's nuts
i don't remember the exact number of
people that actively claim to be jesus
now but it's quite a few like i was
surprised it was like i don't know
15 or something like that people that
actively today that are claiming to be
some sort of messianic figure
you got the white jesus the black jesus
the asian jesus there's probably one in
every culture it really is an oriental
one
right that's true yeah i don't know how
accurate this list is but if you go on
wikipedia it has it for like
18th century it's like two people
[Laughter]
19th century one two three four five six
oh that's interesting more than double
twentieth century uh
a lot more than six is so interesting
you get the 21st century you know and
and there's and it starts to be like
um you know from 1950
onward um obviously this list isn't
conclusive but you can kind of see how
it's
it's ramping up it's increasing you know
more and more and more
i mean you got people on here like you
know charles manson and
son uh young moon and charles manson
claimed he was jesus
i mean yeah i mean these are people
claiming
to be yeah he did in some way whether
it's reincarnated or
the incarnation or the second coming
interesting
yeah when i saw um that newest uh you
guys did a show on it
on the messiah netflix did a whole
series on the messiah
and man just watching the trailer i got
goose bumps because i was thinking my
mind like
wow like not only is this in
you know just the public's mind but now
hollywood is picking up on it and
they're driving that conversation you
know and putting forward that
that storyline that narrative and what
was so incredible when you watch that
trailer
a lot of it is very accurate to what you
would see
in our day like that whole question like
how would how would the us government
grapple with somebody who would come on
the stage and say
i'm like this messiah figure and it's
like we know from prophecy that's going
to happen
you know like governments are going to
have to grapple with that like
you make this transition from a secular
mindset to all of a sudden well
wait a minute like maybe we need to have
more of a religious mindset here
um yeah the first time i watched that i
i saw a part of i thought it was going
to be very
i guess quote scientific because i
thought it would be just
a cult like like i thought the whole
thing was based upon a cult a guy who
called himself a
messiah and then when it got to a point
where i got the scene where he actually
the guy that's the messiah guy he looks
at one of the police officers
and he calls him by his first name and
he starts
reciting i guess something that happened
in the guy's passed with a
child that got killed or something
during a police raiders i don't know
what it was but
that's why i started to look at i'm like
okay this is what they're pushing it's
not just something like oh
it's a cult where this is a movie about
cults and all that right it's actually
just something where they're twisting
the word of god on them like of course
they are yeah think about how deceptive
that'll be when somebody's telling you
very personal things but we know that
you know psychics and mediums and all
this get information from the spirit
world you know
the wicked spirit world so yeah somebody
could really
fool you yeah because if there really is
a demon that's following somebody around
right
and then there's another demon with the
other guy that demon could be
communicating with that demon going tell
him about the guy that when he was young
you know he had a kid oh yeah when you
had a kid and it was like you know
he's thinking he's getting this crazy
information he could just be dictated
from
you know an evil angel right right and
what's so interesting about that too is
um you know
i think they they show you you know all
of these different
contexts where he shows up like he shows
up in in the desert you know where
there's like war and conflict
and he shows up in that tiny town in
kansas where there's a tornado
you know and so the government agents
are asking like you know how is it that
you're appearing in all these areas you
know
and um and again that whole climate
you know whether it be political
spiritual or physical is
driving that conversation for people to
say wow something's happening in the
world and then here comes this
figure that's just like i have answers
right and that's exactly i mean you know
a lot of the other shows and things that
you guys have done as well on
you know comics you know it's like the
whole reason why comics have been
you know um pushing that same narrative
you know
looking for that same type yeah in the
midst of crisis the world's falling
apart
governments are failing you know you
name it whatever
war is looming on the horizon some
external threat is coming to extinguish
earth
who comes to the forefront but a hero
right wow
deadpool yeah like no
it's not like jesus right but all these
issues are polarizing
because you know when you start to
discuss this and if anybody's been a
part of a conversation about climate
just alone about the weather good grief
you know there's there's this opinion
and that opinion
and it gets polarizing real quick and it
gets emotional real quick right right so
it's like you're either with us or
you're against us and so all of a sudden
you start to see how people
get polarized you know and same thing
it's no different with with the
political climate
or even with the social climate right i
mean look we're watching people even
here in the united states where they are
polarizing people groups against each
other
all for the sake of you know causing
that conflict
so that they can then you know there's
division everywhere
racial division uh the climate change
division the corona division yeah are
you sick or not sick
in the church are you saying his name
correctly it's not black jesus why jesus
whatever
it's like even the the the body of
christ is dividing
on these issues that i mean we're just
we're dividing everywhere
so we're going to need somebody's going
to want to step in and say
we need to unite there was actually a
report
that came out where a guy on a plane
actually got up and he threatened to
kill
everyone on the plane as alaska airlines
if they did not
um if they did not realize and
say that jesus was black like literally
he was doing there
it's like i'm gonna kill everybody on
this plane and i'm like
what what what makes you do that like
it doesn't matter who you are what race
you are
whatever just what pushes you to say
those things
right it's right and a lot of it's just
a subtle twist
it's a misunderstanding right i mean
it's like we only have one race
it's the human race right i mean it's
like there's no there's no when you
start to say oh i'm part of this race in
that race no we don't have
six different races or ten different
races on this planet we have one race
there's neither jew nor greek
one family one in christ jesus yeah so
what's amazing is that it's just that
subtle twist
in the conversation where they they
polarize people and
it's because they're trying to create
this
tension because they have a different
agenda they want to bring somebody
that's going to
unite everybody back together and to say
hey look we have a solution
in the face of everything that's
happening the world's falling apart
politics are falling apart
religion's falling apart all these
things are going downhill
well we have a solution for this and
people are so tired i mean i
i really genuinely believe everybody
doesn't matter what side of the issue
you're on
i think people are getting tired of
seeing such division and crisis across
the board
yeah i don't even like getting on
facebook anymore i know it's like
i know it's like it's like on to the
next thing on to the next thing and it's
it's like when the whole racial issue
was happening
i mean people were just like coronavirus
forget that it's onto this like
totally knee-jerk um uh other thing
and then that kind of fizzes out and
dies down and it's like now quick go
back to the coronavirus
the guy that died he had coronavirus
yeah oh my goodness
they're like oh now there's riots and
all these things happening
and it's very selective we see that even
people in the media also they are almost
corroborating with a lot of these other
people the agenda maybe
unknowingly they think that this is a
noble cause but there's something more
sinister behind it
right it's just sowing division and just
so what's interesting is that jesus
actually points out this
this is maybe a shocker to many but
jesus actually points out that this is
just the beginning
and so that to me and and that's that's
hard to wrap my mind around because
like we've been through 2020 has been an
incredibly
busy crazy right yeah this has been the
awful
start to a year first time i ever went
into a bank wearing a mask dude i was
just like
your entire life they tell you like
don't wear a mask you know you could be
taken from the wrong person
you know it's like man 2019 i guarantee
you you walk into a bank with a mascot
and you would be on the floor
a dollar tree actually and the people
looked at me and i saw the
fear in their eyes i was wearing a hood
and a mask and they looked at me and i
i'm thinking oh it's probably they
didn't think i'm gonna rob but they just
i remembered wearing a pandemic it's
okay i'm only here for the pandemic
so but this is the beginning right i
mean there's much more to come
and and that's what is incredible when
you think but there's a shift and in the
context of matthew 24 jesus
actually he he describes this because in
verse 9
he says that it goes from all these
external signs where we see
war famine pestilence you know
earthquakes diverse places all that
all of a sudden he says that that
they're going to persecute
god's people and so like if we're seeing
all these things happening then we know
it's it's a road map
and you can follow it chronologically
what's next stop next
the conversation shifts from all these
external signs that happen around us all
of a sudden
who can we blame yeah who can we blame
why is this happening
yeah and there's somebody that's not
doing what they should be doing
it's interesting that humanity has been
playing the
the blame game since the garden of eden
right right right
and in every situation each uh character
involved if you will
they were the one to blame right nobody
else nobody wants to take responsibility
right so in all of this who is to blame
i am you are
you know and in many ways you know the
people who went
before us and were
yeah we're in this world now jesus is
getting ready to come soon
we're we're the product of many people's
choices in some ways we didn't do those
things you know we're here now dealing
with the consequences
but we still contribute right
and uh ever nobody wants to take
responsibility
you know sin is so destructive and i
just i don't think we ever really fully
grasp
just how destructive it is and one wrong
choice right
and the whole world is thrown into chaos
and
this whole controversy i think has been
really
underlying underscoring that point is
that sin is so toxic it can't
it can't survive you know in god's plan
for the future there can't be
sin right so that he's on a mission to
to prove that
you know he can actually rescue a people
and a people can trust him no matter
what right and make right decisions no
matter what even in the face of
incredible
pressure incredible odds when everybody
else around them
is you know in chaos can we stand and
make
you know the right decision um
only with his help that's right that's
right
so you know the bible actually you know
we actually have a story in the bible
where this actually happens this this
very
situation happens on a mini scale which
has i think large implications for where
we are now
and it comes from first kings 18. if you
remember
uh israel was in a dire famine
you know things were not going well um
and it hadn't rained
action israel for the space of three and
a half years i believe what it was right
and uh and ahab of course is searching
high and low for
elijah because elijah was the one that
pronounced that it's not gonna rain now
oh wow
you know and uh and so he's trying to
find elijah can't find elijah
god hides elijah by the brook remember
he's fed by ravens that whole story
well there comes a point where god you
know says okay now it's time to show
yourself and
and declare to the king that you know
this whole showdown that is
is coming together between those that
worship god and those that
worship man's system and um
and so it's really amazing because you
know ahab actually finally finds elijah
and he actually out of his mouth the
very first thing he tells elijah is like
are you the one that's troubling israel
like he's casting the blame like you
know all of our problems the drought
it's not me
right just so you're saying like i'm not
gonna take responsibility for this even
though ahab is like the super wicked
king he's married to jezebel you know
but he totally calls elijah out and he's
like
you're the one that's causing all these
problems in israel
i like how elijah answers that it's like
no dude
you are the one that you know has caused
us trouble
right but you see the shift right the in
the climate context
you see this shift where all of a sudden
persecution is now
on the table right where it's like okay
i found you and
you know now now there's going to be a
reckoning like we're going to deal with
this
it's interesting because he recognized
i mean he's literally validating that
elijah had the power to
to to stop that i mean by saying you're
the one that caused this or stopped it
right
and you wanted to fix it he's trying to
find him to kill him
thinking that that's going to fix it not
thinking that you know what i mean like
well what really caused this you know go
to elijah and say what
what happened here right and elijah i
think told him in the very beginning
right it's because you have
you know forgotten god and there's going
to be neither do no reign till
you know you guys know who's the true
god is
so i think he knew the problem but he
was ascribing the wrong thing
yeah so it's amazing like the whole the
whole context of the story with elijah
and ahab
is this showdown over worship true
worship
and that's eventually what actually
comes out in the story is you know
elijah basically tells ahab
hey you bring your system of worship and
i'll show up with my system of worship
and let's see who
basically is god and what's interesting
is that you know baal was of course the
deity that they were
worshiping at the time and baal is is
the lord of the dew
and the rain so it's like this god that
is supposed to be able to provide
fertility not just physically but you
know everything else
can't perform um and so there was a lot
on the line
you know this whole false system that
that elijah was up against so maybe the
blame was like elijah's not worshiping
bale and bale's mad
or something right exactly you know and
the pressure there you know it's like
well if we get rid of this guy who's the
hindrance
and then bail will be happy everything's
back to normal he'll send the rain
you know this whole concept you know of
true worship false worship and the
showdown that happens on mount carmel
um you know projecting into now today
like what does this
have you know weight or bearing on us
today like are we headed in a similar
direction would we see
similar you know a similar struggle
between
true worship and false worship yeah i
hadn't thought of it but when you read
that i was just like boom like the
parallels like yeah it's gonna come a
time when
it'll be like if you don't worship this
way then you're
the problem because you know this world
is
actually i see an article where the pope
said that the coron the coronavirus was
mother earth having a fit over climate
change
i'm like whoa why do we have this
religious leader saying
the virus is mother earth having a fit
over
what we're doing to the climate yeah
another little new age terminology there
yeah well it's interesting you bring
that up because um
you know it wasn't too long ago that
that uh pope francis released
you know what la lato c got to see
exactly cool the encyclical that he
released
and it was all specifically on climate
change now embedded in there
interestingly enough
was a really strong push for returning
to sunday observance
in connection with the eucharist
they've actually come out in the news
what is it maybe a few weeks now
where they were really starting to
publicly say you know look at
everybody's had time off
look at how nice this is you get this
day of family we should keep this going
this is great for the environment
so you can kind of already see in our
world they're all preparing for this
day and it's marching more towards the
you know pretty soon it's going to be
not just a good idea take this off you
need to take this off now if you don't
take this off
you're fighting against the status quo
well they've been capitalizing on all of
the world like you know if you look at
um
i think it was venice you know which has
in the past not been known for the
cleanest water
you know you go to venice you get the
gondola you ride down the little canal
it's awesome
but they've actually had a whole influx
of marine life
because they haven't had tourism and so
all their boats and the traffic have
been shut down and their waters have
cleared up
and all these fish and dolphins and
other things have returned and so it's
like a case
study where everybody's like look like
if we shut things down you know like
look what happens like the environment
repairs itself and so there will be a
strong push
you know for you know what we we we've
been pushing too hard
industrialization commercialization all
these things which is true
if you look at it like in a lot of ways
we have way overblown
our boundaries when it comes to
consuming goods and manufacturing goods
because of greed because of selfishness
because of the that i want to
buy it now and i want it to show up my
house two days later and if it doesn't
good grief you know like
it's a problem yeah right i really
really think that life would
though life would not be perfect on
earth it would be
a lot better compared to now if just a
few of the things were not part of our
character and not part of who we were as
human beings so selfishness
right greed all those things if that was
taken out of us i would say today
if god just took that out of us today i
bet you the world would become
way better not perfect but way better
than it was before we had that and it's
just
that's just what it is we destroy
ourselves we break everything that we
touch
yeah and so what's so fascinating is
that is that in this discussion
the things that are being proposed and
brought forward they're not bad
like a lot of the principles they're
bringing forward like you know what we
need a day of rest you know that that's
not a bad thing
in fact god actually says that in
scripture that you know you should rest
one day out of seven now specifically
that being the sabbath you know
what he's commanded but this is where
the twist again it just
just a subtle little change to say well
no it's not sabbath
it's sunday observance in connection
with the eucharist
that is going to going to give us you
know rest and actually change some
things
seems like i remember reading with that
italy thing too they were
not going to go back to business as
usual like
they were purposely going to be less
commercialized and
and things like that i remember also
seeing
shortly after all the you know pandemic
broke out and it was about a month
of things in populated areas just
you know dying down people not out and
about and all this
all of a sudden you're seeing these
satellite images being released
look all this co act co2 activity has
gone
way down look the ozone layer is healing
itself you know
all these evidences that are going to be
used at a later time
to prove this is why we need to
have a day or a have a day of rest they
could they could say it's like uh
enforced quarantine day or something i
mean i've seen
there's a website called green
sabbath.org i think and
there's a lot of that talk in there
talking about one day off
car free sundays i actually saw a news
clip
of it was in canada and they were
talking about this grocery store that
was going to close down on every sunday
and and they were interviewing people in
the parking lot they're like
yeah we need to get back to this we used
to do this you know but we've gotten
away from it and
i think this is a wake-up call we need
to get back to that you know and one
lady mentioned it being the lord's day
and things like that
it's weird seeing all that you know
hearing that talk like that it's
interesting the difference in the way
god does things and the way lucifer does
things
god says this is the way it works best
if you don't do it that way there's
consequences
right right you go to galatians 6 7 it
says god is not mocked whatever man sows
he reaps and satan's way
of doing things it it runs kind of
parallel to god's you know he kind of
starts out that day
that way he'll he'll dangle the carrot
you know the golden carrot you know i
really want you to go along with this
here's a bribe
all that kind of stuff but when the
rubber meets the road instead of him
saying this is the consequence he's like
no you're not going to do it my way i'm
going to force you to do it my way
right no matter what and you just don't
have a choice
right with god you always have a choice
you may not like the outcome
right because that's you chose something
that's going to result in death or
you know dire consequences but you
always get a choice with god
always and that's such a great point god
is one of the biggest
protectors of freedom of choice to do
his detriment
he will protect the freedom of choice
and
you're right on that because you know
this is how you can differ differentiate
between those two systems man's system
of worship
doesn't involve a free choice it's
compulsion
you know it's strongly recommended maybe
at the beginning it's socially pressured
maybe at the beginning
but eventually it's mandated and
eventually if you don't follow the
mandate then it's
legislated if then if you don't fault
the legislation then you're executed i
mean
that's the way that it plays out
constantine did that yeah he like
he outlawed the sabbath but then he said
it's recommended to keep sunday and then
you start seeing these laws about
all the shops must be closed on the
venerable day of the sun and all this
yeah
you may have to fact check me on this
one but i'm pretty sure i remember
reading
that typically the jews long time ago
were
were more or less like two meal a day
type people until it came to sabbath
and sabbath was like three meals we're
feasting we're so happy
it's great you know we're celebrating
early church you know started with
jewish nation jewish jewish converts
started you know moving into gentiles
and
one of the tools that was used was
sabbath the sabbath day became a day of
fasting
and over time sunday became a day of
feasting
right that celebration that that went
with it and so you
you take away you can see like with
sabbath there's the family element
there's the feasting element there's a
celebration element you remove
those things and shift them to somewhere
else and all of a sudden
sabbath's not so popular anymore right
who'd want to do that
that's so lame you see the same kind of
methodology or technique being applied
you know in the bible
in the last days you know what is sunday
going to become it's going to become a
day of family
it's going to become a day of feasting a
day of celebration
right so why would anybody want to do
anything on sabbath you know
well it's interesting too like why why
is it have to be sunday
like why wouldn't they just say hey if
you take a day off
pick your day yeah pick your day if you
want to take tuesday off
what's the deal with tuesday you're
still not using as much carbon
whatever now now you bring up a great
point the question why why does this
have to be sunday and if you actually go
back and
this is maybe a whole other topic for
another show but when you go back
the bible's very specific very clear in
that there's this beast power in
revelation 13
that desires to change times and law and
so there's this controversy where god
has set his seal of approval upon the
sabbath which he's
you know originally mandated from the
beginning and all of a sudden there's
this power that tries to usurp
that authority and say nope this is the
day that we are going to command
as the day of worship and as the as
those two entities of course are
battling for
the hearts and minds of men that's where
we get caught in the whole
decision you know who are we going to
obey are we going to be like elijah on
mount carmel
and stand firm for truth even though it
seems like everybody else is bought into
this system like even elijah bought into
that he was like i'm the only one left
you know every everybody else is you
know well what got in the system
what other religious political figure
has been invited to the united nations
to address this thing
only the pope you know he's the face of
it
and um and to answer your question about
why
why this one day why can't each of you
just take whatever day you want
because you have to have everybody off
in order to shut the factory down or
whatever
otherwise my day isn't your day i got to
work so the factory has to keep going
so they have to pick a day and what
what's the best day to pick
well the mail doesn't run on sunday the
dmvs shut down on sunday you know it's
like
everything's already shut down on that
day like heath was saying
you think oh this is the day of family
what do you think about saturday
the busiest day of the week the busiest
day of the week
most shopped on most going to the clubs
and all this is complete opposite you
know
yeah you know it is very interesting you
think of like what transpires
from friday night to saturday night i
mean the world that's their time to like
you know
produce and party and do whatever you
know go out you tell them to stay home
yeah right
and yeah on sundays at church the rest
of the world is thinking
roger mourinho he actually speaks about
um in an interview that
sunday sabbath is the lord's day and
he was told by a priest that sunday the
great
master was what they called satan he
actually chose sunday as his day of
worship and that sunday was satan's day
of worship
right tristan yeah roger moore know he
was like in the secret society and stuff
cameron
had a really good documentary and book
and everything
definitely something to look into a lot
of people look at sabbath and say oh
that you know that's for the jews
um you know something got instituted for
them but if you go way back
a creation story that's the first time
you see the sabbath commandment
and there's nothing in the sabbath
commandment that's inherently jewish
not at all right there's nothing there
that like would indicate anything jewish
at all it's a
universal for all mankind if you boil it
down to the simplest terms
it's rest and provide rest
for those around you and even animals in
other words it's a rest that's
it's not like lay around and be sleepy
and do nothing
you know it's not that kind of rest but
it's don't enforce
others to be working you
or others around you i mean there's so
many parallels when you look at the
bible that's what i like about
you know you can't just take one thing
out of the bible and all of a sudden
build your
entire thing about it right the bible is
built on these little small
truths that illustrate a larger truth
and
you know the jews making the land rest
every you know
so many years every seven years you have
a year off
and and you know this this i believe
is is god's type and we are
having that same application you know so
on these like little mini scales
and there's this big scale it's the same
thing we see it over and over and over
again
we didn't see it change yeah
so i think you know as as we kind of
wrap this up and
you know this is a huge topic but you
know a lot of people are questioning
like
you know what is happening why are all
these things taking place you know what
the pandemic you know disasters you know
climate change all these things
and i think really when you look at the
bible like
it's the greatest road map that gives us
the greatest confidence for what's
happening now and what's about to take
place even though we may not fully see
it like you kind of hear rumblings
you see little you know tidbits you know
with the papers releasing this statement
or this particular encyclical or what it
may be
and but still even at this point a lot
of people i think would be like nah like
are you serious like there's no way
there's no way there's no way
there's no way that the catholic church
would be the one to rule the world
in and that the united states would be
the right hand arm of the papacy there's
just no way
but the bible has laid out this
this prophetic roadmap to a t
and and you know not none of us are
prophets
but we have prophecy that you can really
you know
trust and and put your full confidence
in and and this is what's amazing
it'll be interesting to see how these
things play out because you know maybe
someone will come back and watch the
show
you know in the future sometimes like
you know what those guys were like spot
on well it wasn't us
no you know it's the fact that god is
foretold that this is what this is where
we're headed this is what's happening
you know and that there will be this
battle between true religion and false
religion and everybody's gonna have to
make a decision where do we stand
you know you know like the revelation 18
23 says you know the light of the candle
shall shine no more at all in the in the
the
the light of the bridegroom shall shine
no more at all me and for the voice of
the bridegroom will not be heard
but by thy sorceries we're all nations
deceived right
right we've dealt with a lot of sorcery
topics
on our uh on our shows um
you know all of the deceptions that are
constantly coming out of hollywood or
whatever
but but it talks about the whole world
will wander after this
entity this entity has this power
over the entire world that they'll
follow after the beast then it's very
interesting to me that
prophecy that's why i like prophecy when
you understand
the prophetic um storyline and and
where the bible illustrated all these
things that were going to come about
god isn't going to do anything until he
reveals it to his prophets first right
so wouldn't you think that that satan's
biggest opus
deception would not be somehow
told in the bible and that we can
actually look at the bible and know
what's coming down the pipe
and so you know when you see all these
things like i i can remember
um watching um you know the the
the catholics you know the pope
having more and more screen time coming
out more in our in our in our world and
being more involved in big political
things and arenas like you said
speaking about the u.n i mean when we
were a kid did you ever see anything
like this
and so when you see that from the great
reformation you understand
how the the protestant movement you know
pinned the
that system of worship as the end time
beast and then all of a sudden we like
you know are seeing this happen in our
day and age it's it's pretty wild to
watch it
talk about what a protestant is then
right you're protesting
where the you know the catholic system
was really gaining
the power and the control but if you
look now the protestants have forgotten
what it means to be a protestant and the
biggest
names the biggest mega churches that get
the screen time
they're saying it's time to unite
they're not protesting
anymore yeah they're actually i mean
i've seen kenneth copeland invite the
pope i've seen
todd white say uh you know let's join
hands with the catholics i've seen
francis chan have
a bunch of catholic priests come out and
pray over all these big name
protestants yeah suppose the protestants
are not protestants anymore and they're
uniting with the beast
and a lot of it is because we just don't
know history yeah you know we've
forgotten history so here's a really
like
important point that just like hit me
like a ton of bricks last year
the the protestant reformation was
essentially
fought over the interpretation of the
bible
right right that's what it was that what
is essentially was about it's either
this system says no i'm interpreting it
for you this is what it means
or you're able to open its pages god
will
communicate with you as you read it
through the power of the holy spirit
and help you learn and understand what
it is that he's getting at
that that was what the protestant
reformation is spot over this
how freedom to interpret the bible
again essentially boiling it down to
freedom of choice
and forced conscience yeah and and with
the whole
climate thing you know a lot of people
will look at that and say
oh it's a hoax you know the planet isn't
really falling apart or whatever
i think it is falling apart i think it's
it's crying out and saying yeah i mean
this is
it's it's being destroyed so i you know
i wouldn't
i wouldn't go so far as to say you know
well it's going to happen anyway
don't do anything right i think if it's
in your power
you know be responsible if it's in your
power
recycle you know use more glass at your
home instead of like plastics and stuff
you know yeah there's a there's a whole
like huge thing in the ocean
this is just this giant mass of plastic
i mean it's
massive i mean it's so big it's just
like heartbreaking to think of that
right you know
is there a documentary called age of
stupid that's all about that so
check that out
human history is littered with the
corpses of people who had stuff worth
stealing
[Music]
animals
water
[Music]
shiny things
fertile land
[Music]
spices
not mixed slice tea
but when it came to stuff worth pinching
one continent had it all
ivory copper cotton rubber wood
tin gold diamonds and people
[Music]
as cheap energy slaves were unbeatable
until the less troublesome energy source
was discovered
and the new era began human numbers
increased five times over
and with each person wanting more and
more stuff oil
became the resource worth fighting for
all
around the world
skiing in the desert
[Music]
heating the air
lighting empty offices energy is so
ridiculously cheap it makes perfect
economic sense to just piss it away
china is the new bad guy because they
are building a new power station
every four days but a quarter of that
energy
makes stuff for us western companies pay
chinese workers crap wages to make crap
plastic toys
then ship them to europe and wrap them
in more plastic
punters drive to the out of town mega
store in their guest guzzlers
plastic toy and plastic box goes into
plastic bags
two days later toy is broken and becky
goes to a chinese landfill where it
stays for about
50 000 years and they now each consume
twice as much energy as the europeans
nine times more than a chinese person
15 times more than their indians and 50
times more than someone from kenya
if all six and a half billion people
here on earth consume like europeans or
japanese
we'd need two more planets worth of
resources
if everyone consumed like americans
australians and canadians
we'd need another four and in 2040 or so
when there's about nine billion of us
you'll need two more again
capitalism's only goal is ever expanding
growth
but ever expanding growth on just the
one not expanding planet
is impossible
the question i've been asking is
why didn't we save ourselves when we had
the chance
[Music]
so you know we're not saying don't just
just throw your hands up and don't do
anything
right you know be responsible as much as
in your power
yeah um and recognizing that the ship
has already struck the iceberg yeah i
mean
the ship is going down it is going to go
down and and this is the biggest thing
is that you know what what's important
you know it's like
at some point you know people mill in a
battle and titanic they're you know
they're still concerned about the band
playing and the lights are on and
you know they're wearing their fancy
clothing and they don't want to put on
that life jacket because it would you
know ruin my fashion you know for the
evening or whatever it would you know
multiplicity of reasons
that in the end cost them their lives
you know like they won't get in they
won't get into that tiny little life
raft why because it's it's
going over that dark edge into like the
icy cold water i'm
i'm comfortable here yeah you know and
so like you know there's this there's
this
um you know really this this need for
christians to
to wake up and understand where we are
in that continuum of time because i know
it seems like the lights are still on
right now and the band's playing
but we're out of time like this the ship
is going down and and what
where then then like what decision are
we going to have
in trying to warn others you know like
it's time to get in a lifeboat
and and that's why it's i'm going to say
this again it's really
important to study prophecy like you've
got to know
where we're at if you don't understand
these concepts there's a lot of channels
there's a lot of things start
investigating it
start with just literally getting on
your hands and knees and praying god
show me up the path god will direct your
path
he'll show you you'll all of a sudden be
stumbling across some other ministry
you know click on those links and and
and watch you know
uh ask god for guidance and the holy
spirit for guidance to understand where
we're at because god has never
ever done anything major without letting
the people know first
right yes and study daniel and
revelation that's right
without knowing who the last power is
going to be then you really don't know
where this is all
going right right but with the statue of
nebuchadnezzar the legs of iron
were rome and the feet were of roman
rome and clay is a mingling of iron and
clay
so we know that that's the last kingdom
before christ comes and sets up his
and you know the things we've brought up
today shows that
this kingdom is getting more and more
screen time more and more publicity
making the cover of time magazine and
all that stuff just seems a little weird
you know
and the world is beginning to look for
the reasons why the world is falling
apart
who's doing this allow we forgot god
and so all of a sudden there's a man
that steps on the scene that claims to
be the authority in the room
of the everything god sits in the place
of god
claiming himself to be god what you just
mentioned we talked about
many will come in my name saying i am
him and all that that's what every pope
does
i am the father yeah i mean i
i literally saw um like a big
u.n type setting like a bunch of
government officials
and they announced the pope as the holy
father
and everybody stands and applauds you
talking about like
obama and people like yeah the holy
father like what
yeah i mean you see those videos of all
the politicians
like literally kissing his hand and
stuff i mean one after another every
world
power and you're just like wow
nobody's no no other religious entity
has that kind of
pull with the world so it's so strange
that
christians you can go through them say
do not commit adultery do not um
disrespect your parents do not do this
does not take god's landing in vain no
other idols
say everything don't kill they'll say
yes yes yes yes yes don't covet they'll
say everything
yes to the minute you bring up sabbath
we're not under the law we're
we're away from the law that why do you
keep sunday well sunday
that was changed the sabbath was changed
but i thought you said we weren't under
the law we aren't under the law and it's
they always find those that are choosing
not to
open their ears they're choosing to turn
around and
find excuses create excuses for why we
don't keep the proper sabbath and i'm
just like
if there's no reason if you're going to
follow the other laws why not this law
why is this one change shouldn't the
other ones
be changed if the sabbath was changed
shouldn't it be that thou shalt not kill
unless they really really anger you thou
shalt not steal unless you
actually want it don't commit adultery
unless your spouse is not making you
happy
anymore like literally there's no reason
for you to go through and
mess with the ten commandments or mess
with one
one of the ten commandments and say oh
all the others are the same but this
one's different
it doesn't make sense a lot for me god
and his infinite wisdom
began the fourth commandment with
remember
because he knew that humanity would be
so easy to forget
and i do want to say this though because
i i don't want to you know leave the
conversation with any sort of slam of
anyone that that that is involved in
in catholicism this is not against
you know we're not saying anything
negative towards people that are a part
of
of of the catholic church so to say god
has his people in every single
denomination i believe that
right we're specifically speaking of
these leaders there
is a group that knows what they're doing
and i mean in prophecy and in the
reformation i mean when you study that
out
yeah we didn't get that wrong you know
what i mean and so
there there is a real reason to be
um you know alarmed with the leadership
but that doesn't mean that just because
you're
you know it's a system problem that's
right you know it's a system problem and
you know just just because
nebuchadnezzar is king of babylon
doesn't mean that he's unreachable
right and that's what's powerful right
it's like the king of babylon
was won because of daniel's witness can
you believe
would you i mean yeah it's the same way
as like if you're
if you're democrat and you look at
republicans all republicans
aren't like trump right and if you look
at
republicans that are looking at
democrats all democrats aren't like
obama you know it's like yeah you know
you gotta
learn to deal with people and and see
them for who they really are not
not what they're necessarily their
system represents
right um there's always been two though
throughout history
two sides like my grandfather he was
former he used to be catholic
he said that it's not the people the
people are great people he said it's the
system it's the people that
it's the leaders he said that and i'm
like just from the mouth of a person who
was
an altar boy who i believe doing
probably not not to become a priest but
an altar boy and
he knew the eucharist and he knew the
like tobias and
all that those things he was really into
it and he's telling me this it's not the
people it's the leadership
yeah you know who the three most
recognized people in the world are
mickey the pope and mario
from our brothers you got one of them
president of the united states um
queen of england and the pope oh well
three most recognizes
faces faces current faces on the planet
and isn't that fascinating you know
that's that's that's two
out of the major key players in the in
the end of time the united states and
the paper city
right yeah that's powerful yeah and one
was really born out of the other all
right
man we need we need some courageous
laborers today
you know we need some elijah's we do and
and and you think about what elijah must
have felt standing on
the top of mount carmel you know by
himself like literally
thinking he went up to there thinking
that i'm the only one
i mean all these people are you know on
the other side but look at the
miraculous
um display of god's
true power and and that he's the one in
control of this whole thing
that you know elijah got to witness and
be a part of that yeah
and i think that's kind of where the end
of the end time people are going to be
at too
it is really god we need to know
are we doing what god wants us to do not
what any other system
or any other thing like go to your bible
go to the source of truth
read that for yourself i really think
that you know you guys need to
investigate
the subject of the sabbath just look
into it read the verses do some digging
on it
and more importantly if you start out
that study
pray that god leads you in that study
and shows you the truth and i believe
that if you really honestly are a truth
seeker and praying god will not
fail you it's fascinating about this
chapter of revelation 13
and you have elijah on mount carmel
that miracle that was performed was to
confirm um an already existing truth
right it's an already existing truth you
get to revelation 13
it's the other way around the mir the
miracle is used to confirm
something that's not already an existing
truth
right right it's kind of it's kind of
putting the heart the cart before the
horse
right and it's like well see the miracle
therefore this must be true instead of
this is already true here's the miracle
to back it up right and the way they're
described
very similar now whether it plays out in
revelation 13 exactly like
you know it did in elijah's time where
it's fire from heaven
i don't know exactly revelation is full
of signs and symbols
but it's interesting that they're
described the same way
they're both over the issue of worship
but you have to think about what's the
most important thing the most important
thing is
what did god say yeah yeah right and
that's because the devil can't he you
can't create
he can't be original he can only reverse
engineer so he can only go back
and try to you know manipulate that it's
interesting you said
you know elijah was like i'm the only
one that's a parallel for where we're
gonna be
the remnant the remnant which keep the
commandments of god they're the ones
that satan hates
and is going to make war against so like
you said study this out
you want to be in that remnant even if
it means
getting your head cut off i mean satan
hates you he's coming after you
we are the biggest threat those who obey
god rather than men
because those people are literally a
walking breathing demonstration
of the power of god like in elijah's
experience that fire coming down from
heaven
it was like the people immediately saw
that and just went okay he's gone
right so when we have a group of people
that love god so much that they love not
their own lives even unto death
then people will look at that and say
that's the glory of god
look at that the character of god i mean
it's what it's all about i mean
we're coming to the final showdown
between the character of god and the
character of
man as displayed in satanic influence
and that's the polarization that we're
seeing and so who whose character will
we choose
you know today gods are
a whole host of options i think it's a
great place to leave it
we hope you guys enjoyed this little
discussion well it wasn't really little
this is probably a much bigger
discussion than
we can handle in an hour um but please
if you have any questions we'd love to
hear from you um but seriously consider
um looking into this subject looking
into the the study of the reformation um
you know understand history look back
and uh
especially if you are a protestant you
know and and
you're still in a protestant uh tism
so to say um make sure you know what you
believe and why you believe it
and we'll put some links in the
description below for you to
follow find the study hopefully you'll
do it and
thank you for once again for tuning in
and hope you like
this video subscribe to our channel if
you haven't before
and of course uh check us out we got
lots of ways to support our channel
patreon
buying t-shirts you name it uh we thank
you guys so much for
your love and support so we'll catch you
guys later see ya
[Music]
you